[Musica]
penati ragazzi e benvenute questo nuovo
video sono fa dj ed oggi siamo su dello
yen ragazzi in occasione di halloween
ho deciso di fare un video completamente
conciato così a dir la verità sembra una
sola di quella che ritenevano quando ero
piccolo ma non fa niente
direi ordona avanti alla ragazza in
questo e di halloween e dagli stessi
produttori ragazzi di mouse egido che
moro cfc tanto tempo fa perché si
sentano tutti qui da top c'è una zucca
che una zuccata station fuori genere pc
sta cazzo
allora ragazzi dobbiamo riuscire a fare
qualcosa in sto videogame e ragazzi io
non so dove chiasso siamo ma una cosa è
certa il sangue non lo pulisco io quindi
date cid olio di gomito perché qualcuno
deve pulire qui e non vogliamo mica
lasciare tutto sporco vero ragazzi che
cosa succede
affinito che lei il ragazzo ha sentito
il rumore bruttissimo non so dove la non
importa veniva avanti così
devo far ciò si stava a perfetto
buongiorno ragazzi qualcuno di voi ha
ordinato una zucca lampadina no per
tenere una è gratis la vivendo su ebay
al massimo allora mi stai prendendo per
il culo non ritocca fatti vedere fatti
vedere se le palle forti vede cosa
questo halloween una festa che si tiene
il 31 ottobre plan sono solite stronzate
che spiega noto giallo per gli alieni
che si mettono a giocare sto video che
non sanno ancora che cos'è sbagli tiro
c'è allora io e te dobbiamo fare una
chiacchierata ok vediamo che al sorriso
più bello stronzo vinto io a ragazzi che
cazzo ci sono tu amico mio sul cartello
si sta scritto chiaramente che è vietato
volare in sostanza ok ma perché qualcuno
quando non serve avere i ragazzi questi
ragazzi non lo sto capendo c'è qualcuno
che traduce qui perché mi sembra che
stia parlando ara poco che nel gene
quindi va poco monelli bambini che
giocano a pallone di fuori e mi rompono
la finestra ma guarda un po io non farei
dolcetto scherzetto la fabi gente vi
giuro che rimarca vini sono rifatte
essendo giorni prendo a calci stessa
roba che scannerizza questo è una foto
di facebook ragazzi non so che cos'è si
sta aprendo ditemelo suoi ragazzi alla
casa terrificante come penso cazzo anche
peggio
sarà anche quello chi se ne fotte
andiamo avanti colore dipende nei miei
sogni che ha scordato di voi bastardi mi
avete rotto la finestra la pagherete
cara che cazzo se la cupolina graziato
gioco te la tizia di dei grassi che mi
ha [ __ ] la giunta giustamente bene
così non è normale che sia ma c'è un
coso vino si capisce questa non è la mia
zucca ho detto che devi portarmi qui la
zucca non me ne frega del testo dei
bambini è questo succede quando ronde
tele fine strappa vigente perché se
un'ombra di pietro che mi sta pensando
maleficamente perfetto se futa se fuso
alla luce a vanno mai fabi ciascuno di
noi si porta niente fottuti oggi a lato
che tornata bene così ragazzi abbiamo
finito da lui non ci posso credere
e ricordatevi che bambini sono sono
proprio stronzi cazzo cioè non c'è
niente da fare alla ragazzi a sto punto
io direi di fare anche di haus che non
ha ancora fatto
io ho fatto di out due quello fatto di
halloween e mi manca mi manca di amazon
o ancora non l'ho fatto ragazzi visto
che è durato poco direi di fare un si è
chiesto perché sono masochista cazzo ti
house ragazzi stiamo per entrare nella
casa quella la vecchia mese anche la
casa di topolino è più o meno la stessa
cosa comunque l'accordo è stato
costruito nel 1900 e farmi leggere cazzo
perché siete tutti così scortesi oggetti
in saldi tra dentro adesso visto mai
tanto di fretta chi sfonda la porta così
a sono entrato son centrato perfetto
ragazzi preparatevi perché andiamo
subito a prendere il caffè in cucina
fantastica la casa di accoglienza epica
mai di farmi una fan art no perché se
sei un fenomeno cazzo vabbè ce l'ha ma
c'è una palla tranquilla non essere
aggressiva che ti affari arriva ho detto
contento non essere aggressiva che devi
fare la prova bambino zio farlo in un
porto ad oggi neanche aperta magari foto
la palla perché non riesco cos'è un
giorno e si entra dalla porta lo sai che
scortati entrare dalla finestra amico
mio
dovetti che ha segnato l'educazione
fammi capire non si bucano i palloni
tagliate ma che sono maleducati ricordo
ok ok ci sono finiti i capelli in faccia
scusatemi ragazzi che mi si rovina la
piaga qui ma vai alla prossima stanza
perfetto e bordata e volete una testa
ragazzo in si giochi volano teste per
bambini non si fa per dire un cesso
amena quali questo livello di piazzetta
c'è il gesto così semicalvo addosso su
dove andare dal centro
buon compleanno mamma se è bella festa
fendi le candeline
mica costa mascherano gli è stato per un
cazzo va beh sappiamo che è sofferto di
magione malattia ma sappiamo anche che
guarirà presto ti voglio bene fantastico
ma lettera molto commovente
scarichiamo l'accetto
ragazzo gioco mi piace fila
il colluttorio e dillo subito che saprà
parla vostri denti
mica capito ecco se voglio bene anch'io
bimbi non vi lascerò ve lo prometto
siccome lettere a passaggi le tante ma
chissenefrega se arriviamo anche questa
si si lo so che ti serve accesso cinque
minuti ho finito tranquilla ragazzi
dobbiamo far riflettere qui la gente si
sta alterando perché lì sempre accesso
ok ho incassato la vasca cazzo ed adami
altri due minuti in più che qua è
successo un pò un casino ragazzi state
mino stura lavandini cazzo che non
tassato la vasca non volevo 20
qualcuno qualcuno si chiama la vita un
ok di gatto è già sotto processo
un'altra mattino ed esco ho finito ho
detto che ho finito non mi rompere le
palle ho detto che ho finito un secondo
che ho finito se la mafia accesso è
tutto ok ok ci fossi tu ci pensino
perfetto me ne vado me ne vado me ne
vado bene cos'è ragazzi ricordatevi che
se per caso seattle accesso se non
riuscito a mettere addosso l'estate farà
gli altri perché mi sa che è meglio
perfetto si può cliccare qua dentro
questa
ok è bellissima bambola trame la
regalità se questo è lo abbiamo capito
così calendario
non ho visto niente io prima non ci ho
fatto caso ho visto qualcuno che se ne
andava ma non avevo visto prima chi
c'era buio sta cosa devo rivedere che
non ho capito ma mi guarda don detto già
venti volte che non si deve volare per
la stanza ma che cazzo punti che
trasgrediscono le regole qui maledetto
cos'è è cascato un volantino fantastico
cos'è vabbè ragazzi coach e il codice
fiscale che cazzo me ne faccio di sta
roba non lo so io voglio la bambola io
sto ancora cercando di capire chi c'era
qui non ho ancora capito
cazzo è caduto sento signora si usano le
scale non ha mai detto nessuno che
esistono le scale bene si usano anche le
gambine non c'è bisogno di tirarsi giù
dal soffitto idiota ragazzi qua la gente
scortese come non so cosa lasciamo stare
the live in rome the line con quanta
stanza perfetto ragazzi ci stiamo
avvicinando la fina non vedo l'ora
perché mi sto di giorgio ancora mille
anche se non sembra
avete un quanto sei bello ragazzi non mi
non vi sentite a tratti sessualmente la
sto tizio va beh mi importa andiamo
avanti così mettiamo dove lo zoo di 105
a cazzo sospettati anche che in
gestazione la bora che chi se ne frega
della radio andiamo avanti così non so
chi cazzo c'è la chicca la parte
segretario hanno capito queste radio
maria venera 200 c dove prenderli per il
culo ragazzi è desti mettono le stazioni
a caso qui non hanno mica capito che i
sorgenti quadri ragazzi prendono
l'iniziativa e guardano male come se
fosse come se niente fosse che
maleducati sonno cos'è avevi così di
lipari lurido stronzo
aveva solo non guardarmi male adesso
rimane lì non piaccio più ok che c'è qui
dietro
scusami madonna che calligrafia brutta
cosa mi addio tesoro non si capisce una
sega la stata così fortunata di averti
conosciuto e ti amerò per sempre che
bella lettera ragazzi
non ho capito non ha capito che mi serve
la pistola ma non importa
ok forse ho capito cosa mi serve
effettivamente non lo so ho detto che
non mi devi guardare male solo sono ecco
infatti te l'avevo detto e ma so che
adesso hai poi cioè io glielo io gliele
di co ste cose poi sono cambiati
gioca ma è così impara pronta ultimo
stanza il corridoio che bello non vedo
l'ora di vedere che belle cose ci sono
in questa stanza c'è la luce mica si
accende vero mica si accese non ci posso
credere
la prima volta che si accende la luce in
un horror senza che faccia casino
scusami dio per quello che ho fatto amo
la mia famiglia ho dovuto ucciderla era
l'unico modo per stare con loro per
sempre ragazzi non sentite halloween che
vi penetra nelle viscere con questo
fantasma non spegne lo accendi la pure
grazie molto gentile cioè la cos'altro
qui non ci sono saletto alla fine robur
ragazzi non ho capito che devo fare il
fango accendo la luce come un ritardato
di un giorno ho trovato un biglietto non
so che il suo accendi titoli da stronza
brava qualcosa mi dice che si accusa la
luce ma non voglio indagare
andiamo avanti così ragazzi perfetto
perfetto perfetto perfetto perfetto la
situazione una vera merda un giorno me
ne vado via subito
non ho già fatto io accesso
d'andata sono andata perfetto nostro
data center ragazzi è stato fantastico
non ci posso credere
ti giuro sto aspettando un secondo che
sto morendo di caldo mio dio santissimo
va bene ragazzi ho sempre sognato di
fare un video in maschera comunque e ci
sono riuscito finalmente comunque la
cosa era successo anche a natale mi
hanno messo il caso di babbo natale
probabilmente lo farò anche quest'anno
ma questo lo vedremo più avanti
spero che comunque video vi sia piaciuto
vidi ragazzi se vi do è piaciuto il come
al solito lasciato argomento mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook e come in
ogni video trovate nella descrizione
sede del ris chiti iscrivetevi ci
rivediamo in un prossimo vito bella
ragazzi e buon halloween